I feel that some structural changes
could really unlock this department's
potential Jerry hmm I believe you were
capable of much more
I'm not nonsense look in the mirror huh
you are an intelligent charismatic
beautiful superhero I'm making you head
of public relations which means you'll
be leading the daily briefing sessions
excellent idea
this is my favorite part about having a
new city manager they always try to
shake things up and their ideas are
terrible and it brings City Hall to a
grinding halt I just grabbed a few
doughnuts sit back and enjoy the show
April you are too valuable to just be
Ron's assistant so from now on you are a
multitasking executive aide that's the
sting the entire office is this a
nightmare April wake up Tom I just want
to say that you are a wonderful employee
and a terrific human being meeting
adjourned
I enjoy you you know what else I enjoy
your entrepreneurial spirit I did
recently sell my Chronicles of Riddick
DVD on eBay for $10 use the profits to
buy the blu-ray that's terrific
I have an amazing project for someone of
your talents you are going to digitize
the entire city archives up on the
fourth floor no I hate the fourth floor
last time I was up there I saw someone
buy crystal meth out of a vending
machine it's a bad place you won't be
alone
Andy starting now you are nobody
shoeshine boy starting now you are an
administrative assistant for three weeks
then back to shoes Chris I wasn't super
paying attention to what you just said
that we'll be doing but I will give a
hundred and ten percent
what soon as you repeat yourself in a
more interesting way I got a second box
of doughnuts if anybody what this this
mr. director is your new desk
okay this desk is the epitome of the
Swedish concept of a young stud ducked
or equality imagine someone needs your
attention somebody say my name Chris
swivel what is Jerry you told me to say
your name and you did a great job
superstar someone else say something
you look like a freak swivel April that
is not a very good attitude I will keep
my eye on you from my circular desk
where I can see everything
tiny swivel see how it works what about
my office and its many walls that
becomes a new public waiting room and we
got rid of that giant pillar that was in
front of your door
I loved that pillar and made it really
annoying to stand in my doorway get over
it
cuz it's gone you're gonna be more
accessible than ever people behead that
usage report that I asked for anything
for you Jerry thank you
oh come on why excuse me there's a sign
at ramsett park that says do not drink
the sprinkler water so I made some tea
with it and now I have an infection sir
sir are are you are you are you
listening to me sir sir I'm talking to
you sir sir are you aware that there is
a waste in the water system
you